la fin d'année c'est aussi l'occasion de
remettre des récompenses la deuxième
édition du prix de l'innovation urbaine
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine s'est déroulée récemment cérémonie
à la scène musicale à boulogne
billancourt
l'objectif mettre en avant les projets
portés par les maires des deux
départements au total sept prix ont été
décernés parmi les communes récompensées
poissy lauréat dans la catégorie
innovation architecturale paysagère et
environnementale pour la reconstruction
de la maison de faire c'est un édifice
historique de la ville est la réaction
du maire au micro de justin brazès moi
je suis né à poissy donc c'était plus un
passionné david de poissy est un
passionné de l'histoire de la ville de
poissy et cette transmission pour nos
générations futures qui a fait que petit
à petit je vais pas dire pièce après
pièce mais on a essayé de rendre et de
m'être donné notre tôle à l'édifice
aujourd'hui ça devient musée
exceptionnel avec le concours du
département des yvelines c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je suis très ému de me
retrouver ici dans dans cette enceinte
inter-départemental le concours de la
région de la ville
évidemment et puis un vrai travail
collectif qui me fait dire que le seul
on va plus vite mais ensemble on va plus
loin